I'm coming to the end of my long term as
a district counselor I was first elected
in 1995 and I'm often asked would I do
it all over again and I certainly would
I think it's been an amazing experience
for me personally and also you feel you
might have made a small difference here
and there you will get a great deal of
support from officers at the council and
I'm still learning although I'm in this
final year as a counselor I'm retiring
next May i'd like to support all of you
who are considering standing whatever
political party or none because you will
make a difference
there will be frustrations but mostly
you will be in the thick of it you will
be doing your best to assist people
would also involve in many major
decisions that District Council's have
to go through and I wish everybody well
I know it's been an excellent
opportunity for me in my life and I know
with the supportive staff of the council
you'll have inductions you'll have an
awful lot of training and you will have
considerable support throughout your
time
you